hey everyone welcome to the walleye
podcast i'm james marshall and before we
get to today's episode a quick mention
to our partners who have helped bring
this episode to you and kept the podcast
going firstly todd's racing champion
harness trainer regan todd who's a lad
who just wanted to help out the podcast
so in return let's help him out by
following todd's racing on facebook and
twitter also the waterlag coffee bean
has impressed anyone who's given it a go
freshly roasted in nelson by pomeroys if
you enjoy your coffee you will love this
bean to order head over to waterloo.com
click the coffee link up the top and
you'll be away anyway i have an amazing
guest on for you today so let's get to
it
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
okay right oh guys i have a very special
guest for you all today refereeing is
such an interesting part of the game
that we all love so i'm stoked to have
one of the best in the world on woodland
today he's refereed at all levels
including super rugby the six nations
even the rugby world cup and he's
recently returned from the lions tour of
africa and above all like all my guests
are he is an absolute lad he's one of
the greats it is of course the man
himself ben o'keefe welcome mate cheers
jeremy what an introduction
it's awesome to be on what a lad so um
thanks mate thanks for having me hey
mate awesome to have you on like i said
you're freshly back from this massive
tour lions against south africa look
like one of the most intense tours of
all time how was it to be out in the
middle of all that well it was um it was
pretty crazy like um you know speaking
of intensity it was it was definitely up
there probably one of the most intense i
guess fixtures but also series that i
think has ever been in terms of lines
like i knew it was going to be be pretty
big like um you know every line series
comes with their
um intensities controversies talking
points and and certainly you know the
one that i've just come out of um
offered offered plenty but it's sort of
offered plenty right from the get-go so
um it was a pretty busy three weeks um
it was up there in terms of like uh one
of those experiences
um that i remember about uh yeah man
it's good to be home really good to be
sort of back and uh
back into a bit of safety
yeah mate for sure and i watched that
second test the one where you're in the
middle i watched it with just the ref
comes on and man i was blown away with
how much you had to deal with throughout
that game you've got the tmo constantly
in your air you've got your assistance
you've got players constantly talking to
you're trying to calm everyone down
because there's a fair bit of biffo
going on and it's just and that's not
even including the actual refereeing of
the game where there's so much pressure
on you to get that right so mate is it
as hard as it looked well that's you
forget like that was without having the
crowd either so we had one less um you
know element uh involved there so yeah
that was it was full on and i think uh
you know listening to the to the refcoms
you just you do realize that actually
there was a lot going on in the
background and um it didn't help that
that game went on for two hours either
so i had you know two hours worth of
players and coaches and
and you know tmo decisions so um like it
was it was full-on but it was just one
of those games that like it just needed
like what happened in that game we just
had to get amongst it and um every sort
of hurdle that we had to get through it
started in the first two minutes and it
just continued for for the rest of the
game so um i feel sorry for you having
to listen through all that but um you
know kept me on my toes and and my boys
on the top on their toes you know having
to to get through that game and you know
because every little thing that we're
having to to deal with you know was
something that you know i needed the
other guys to be talking to me
constantly and i needed the tmo to be in
my ear as well because that's a gamer
rugby now you know you can't really just
be the one solely referring it in the
middle you actually need your you guys
on the sideline and the man up in the
box to yeah to help you out just to give
you a feel for what's going on yeah mate
you must be really good at multitasking
because you're having this conversation
with the tmo while still trying to
referee the game it's like trying to do
two things at once that men supposed to
won't be able to do yeah mate look
obviously yeah naturally being a male
you don't you know i struggle with that
but um it's just like anything you know
it's just it's just practice um and
certainly over the years it's become
more of a and i always tell my assistant
referees mitmo you know just just tell
me like i love communication just at
down time uh during live play you know
um tell me what you're thinking tell
what you're saying and then i'll be able
to make a decision and i'll be able to
make a better decision based on that
context so it's definitely something
that over time i've just tried to
develop
and i'm glad i did because i definitely
needed it in that game because mata was
it was full on warfare from from the
start yeah and even before the whole
game there was a controversial video
from resi
posting our one hour yeah thoughts piece
to towards i guess the public and the
refs i guess but how much of an impact
did that have on you did you watch it at
all no matt like that was i mean what
happened was unprecedented really in
terms of what a coach had done um i
guess publicly more than more than not
because i mean you probably know you've
been through team meetings and um
coaches you know after a game they'll
always send clips to referees and you
know sometimes you know i've been up to
six nations before and they'll actually
send you there'll be 30 clips that i'll
send you
a lot of it's around clarity on what
their team is doing clarity on decisions
and also some things you know maybe to
help you in the future so it's it's
quite common that that happens um but it
happens with a certain protocol in the
background so they'll send it to you
you'll go through you'll do your own
review and then you know sort of by the
monday tuesday um that's when you'll
give your reply so it's not uncommon for
that to happen for coaches to to to send
out their opinions and sometimes they
are a bit of motive in that email but
it's all behind the scenes
um so it was unprecedented really is
that how it sort of you know everything
was aired publicly and
um it certainly you know put a lot of
things in perspective for us because you
know we did we do a massive review after
every game and we realized from that
first test you know there were
definitely things as a team you know we
needed to work on
um but you know like if a coach puts out
30 um
clips
post game you know i could do that in
every game that i've ever done
i could do probably 50 because the
game's so subjective you know there's a
lot of things that
um errors you make or non-decisions that
you make
that you know you're trying as a referee
you're trying to lessen that in the game
so it doesn't have as much impact but
there's still always going to be that
you know if you look at it through one
side you're going to pick out 30 things
if you look at it from the other team's
perspective you're going to be able to
do the same as well yeah
so that was the biggest thing so we when
we did our review we realized look
there's stuff there that we need to fix
as well the tmo process you know the
amount of communication that we we do
together to make the right decision
um so we went through and we reviewed
that
and then i remember coming back from the
gym on a tuesday and i read one of the
articles um and i try not to you know
read too much media the week of the game
but it said about this video that had
come out and i was in the car with um
nick berry who was referring that game
and he said yeah mate i received it last
night and it's full on and then when i
got back to
have lunch with one of the south african
guys that was in our bubble
and the first thing he said when we
walked in is like boys do not watch that
video and and i was sort of thinking it
was a bit of a joke yeah um i didn't
realize the extent of it until you know
it came out the media um caught on to it
and it was just like teeing off in the
background
and i said to him i was like mate so
like how bad is it you know like should
i should i watch it at all and he said
one thing you should not do this week or
probably ever is ever watch it so so to
be fair like the way it's played out um
i haven't seen it i think i've got
better things to do than watch you know
um one man's a opinion for 62 minutes um
so so like how did it impact us i think
it really just helped us focus to
realize that okay
we do need to be better as a team um
this weekend but we've sort of already
worked that out in our review process um
and what it kind of did was you know for
me personally it kind of fired me up a
little bit because i felt like you know
it was a bit of a personal attack on the
team um on officiating in general and
you know you know the line was crossed
so i felt like okay i've got a bit of a
responsibility to to put a good
performance out there so that you know
people can just start talking about the
game again about
um you know lime series versus you know
they're officiating yeah did you mention
it to rassi before the game you
obviously speak to him before the game
no well so
you know what's normal as well is that
we have a coach meeting um always before
the test on the saturday and
that coach's meeting um normally is in
person but it was over zoom in these
situations and in those meetings they
normally you sort of bring up okay these
are things that we've done or these are
things that we've been working on all
week you know is it okay often they
might bring up a few things that the
other team does but you know very really
by then we've done our preparation you
know we've obviously off more than often
or not we've actually seen clips that
they bring up but you know very really
does actually influence us
uh so we had that meeting and you know
we were preparing you know which of the
south african coaches were going to be
on the call obviously with the lions you
know you had warren gatlin who was on on
their cool as well so so we didn't
actually see him on the call it was just
uh uh jacques the um staffing or the
springbok coach that was on that call so
um yeah it was a good discussion we
basically you know outlined you know
what we thought about what had happened
during the week and yeah we just you
know the point of that meeting was
really just trying to reassure them that
okay despite what's happened in the
media this week you know we haven't
really been uh reading too much into it
we know there's a few things we need to
work on um but it's not going to have
any impact on how we referee this
weekend and and we need you know your
team to trust that you know we're just
going to do our job um and so therefore
you guys can just do your job and not
worry about all the external stuff
and i think they sort of took that on
board and they said okay great okay
these guys are really just to go out
there and referee so therefore we can
you know we can trust that you know
they're going to do that we can just
trust and do our game as well so
yeah we should we actually didn't see
them until um obviously had the water
boy water boy bib on but i you know we
didn't really take too much notice we
just
head down and um just tried to repeat
the game that it's interesting hey and
you spoke about your prep coming up to
the game and what else is involved with
that prep i mean it sounds way more
intense and people would get it yeah i
think like i mean i've had heaps of
people you know throughout my career you
sort of turn up you might be yarning to
players after the game i'd be like oh so
do you guys actually do any work before
a game or do you just rock up and i
think a lot of people think we just sort
of yeah chuck on the copers and then
just rock up onto a field and blow the
whistle but
um no we definitely do a lot more work
work than that and certainly you know
the more the more work you do the better
performance you'd give sort of put out
in the weekend
um but i sort of alluded to it you know
you you review the game from the weekend
before to try and pick up on anything
that you need to to work on specifically
from that game
um and then you know much like teams
like we we try and preview you know the
two teams that we are referring in the
weekend and previewing it is really just
based on okay what does this team like
to do um how do they try and play are
they you know do they go a lot of line
out to mall um do they try and scrum for
penalties um do they try and spread the
ball why because a lot of it's really
around okay how do i get into the right
position to to make the right decision
yes i mean a lot of that which is team
specific um and we've got coaches and
people that help us do that and then
the rest of the week apart from doing
all your physical stuff like um running
and you know a bit of gym work a lot of
it is around just okay getting getting
my philosophies and my game plan
um so that i can refrigerate the tackle
quickly i can refree the scrum i can
refer the line out and so i've got a
blueprint that i've developed over time
and that's what roofers do you sort of
develop an understanding for a game much
like a player and so i'm just constantly
trying to reinforce that and you know
sometimes it will mean that you know i
have to go out into a field and practice
my positioning because i was a bit off
the week before
i have to go down to a team training
just to you know help refree you know
their scrums and you know it puts
pictures in front of my head so i can uh
be good at referring that
or i just have to sit down there's lots
lots of clips around you know teclas and
you know jacqueline's getting on the
ball just so that you know i'm a bit
quicker um in the weekend so
a lot of that is the preparation i'll do
during the week and um you know for
example that line series that's exactly
what i did
but what i try and do is i try and you
know front load a lot of it so that
monday tuesday wednesday the bulk of my
work is as in the theoretical stuff
happens then so then by thursday and
friday sort of a game you know the night
before
i'm really only you know thinking maybe
one or two things so i can just wake up
on saturday um have a fresh mind and
then just go and just trust okay you've
done the work you know you can just have
confidence in you know how you've been
referring this year anyway just go out
there and blow the whistle because there
are times when you know much like exams
i used to do i was always trying to like
study the night before i was trying to
cram the morning of an exam and i go out
and try and do the exam and i tried to
do that with rugby really and
i remember i had a chat with gilbert
anoka one year because you know my games
are real up and down i was having good
games having bad games i was quite
inconsistent and he asked me what my
process was and i sort of said look i
just i just try and study the game and
study how i'm going to referee every day
friday night and saturday morning and he
said look if he had if you know one of
his all blacks on his players was still
going through all their notes this
saturday morning he'd grab that book and
throw it out he just wants one or two
key things for for their players and so
i took that on board i trialed it when i
was referring um south africa vs france
i sort of i talked and talked to them
about three years ago on the monday and
i thought oh i might as well try it
because you know i've got to try
something different and yeah it worked
really well um so
yeah so i try and i try and just do that
and um it often means i try and play a
bit of golf on the friday as well just
to clear the head um because that can be
quite challenging too you know like you
hit a bad shot which happens a lot for
me um and you've got to just move on you
know it's the same thing in a game yeah
make a bad decision and you just got to
move on so
um i quite like uh sort of where i'm at
in terms of how i prepare mate there's
so much to a day way more than people
could ever imagine i'd imagine so is it
different for a when you're refereeing
compared to when you're an assistant or
a tmo does does your prep change at all
yeah it does like probably the extent of
how much you prepare um yeah you know
we're you know the lead referee and
you're preparing for how you're going to
lead that team and refree um in the
weekend you know you're doing a lot of
the work you're actually
you know you'll lead a lot of the
meetings that you'll have during the
week with your assistant referees and
your tmo because you'll probably catch
up maybe once or twice around okay this
is what i'm saying or guys i want you to
actually do a bit of work on you know
you're going to be on the side of the
scrum so once you have a look at
how this how this team operates at scrum
time so you know you'll then catch up
and then go through sort of those key
things that you think is important for
this game just so that you're on board
yeah so the referee will do a lot of
that but as an assistant referee you
know you actually have to train yourself
that week because the worst thing you
can be as an assistant referee is try
and replay the game you know you're
actually as the assistant referee on the
sideline you're more focused on you know
watching you know space offsides and we
have all this different type of role
clarity when a kick goes up so you've
got a contestable kick you know the
referee is actually going to be watching
the contest in the air where the
assistant referee's going to be watching
the escort running um on that on that
sort of ground plane so
you've got to sort of train yourself
okay this weekend on the assistant
referee i've got actually um change what
i'm looking at what i'm focusing on i'm
going to be at the front of the line out
so i need to actually be focusing on you
know the front pod what they do in the
year
does this team suck are they coming in
the side of the mall so you really have
to change where you're looking at
because
if you don't then you know you're
basically going to be missing things
that you referee need you to do to
achieve that weekend so
there's definitely that aspect and then
if you're the assistant if you're the ar
one um there is a chance if you know
you've got an old fellow referring um
they pull up a bit of a calf injury um
you have to jump on and you know that's
certainly happened to me a few times
that's how i got my super rugby debut
when um chris pollock rolled his ankle
doing
skipping or something in the morning of
his game and then he gave me the call up
and he said you're out there so you sort
of have to prepare knowing that okay
what am i gonna do
um if the scenario means i have to
actually run onto a field you know
halfway through or even before the game
were you prepared as a young fellow then
being the ar1 were you prepared for your
debut that day made like from honestly
yeah
no way you know like i just thought i
was just going to rock up i was i was
still getting used to being the one yeah
um
and uh when i got the phone call from
him i thought he just wanted to catch up
for coffee but i sort of walked in he
was hobbling he had this massive ankle
on him
so we took him down and you know got a
mix rate and everything and
um i didn't really realize until
afterwards it was about midday where i
got the phone call from lyndon bray it
was our boss and he said well you're up
and i thought what does that mean you
know um and then you know obviously it
dawned on me i was gonna referee super
rugby game which is gonna be crusaders
highlanders um you know which if anyone
was born in the south island you know
it's a big it's a mess of derby and um i
thought okay
what would i normally do during the week
well i normally have five days of
preparation well i've got about four
hours so what am i going to do
so i went back to hotel i just slept
and then got up and just then just went
out and refereed and i remember walking
off the game being like that was
absolutely fantastic i loved it yeah and
then about six or seven sightings came
through of foul play that i missed and i
realized i had a lot of paperwork i
needed to do so
um yeah but it was a certainly good
experience that one oh mate that's good
times but before we get too far into
your refereeing career we need to go
back to the start and we got a pb of
questions come on for you i mean
everyone wants to send in the referee
questions so you've got plenty to finish
this podcast with but we need to start
at the start like always growing up in
blenheim what was your childhood like my
childhood's amazing you know it's one of
the best space town in the top of the
top of the south island um in tasman
a lot of sunshine hours so
i loved it um went to marlborough boys
and you know it was great growing up
here it's i kind of loved growing up in
a small place because it was very easy
around
you know footy trainings you play all
types of sports because you know you
could basically bike everywhere and
um yeah i said mulberry boys you know
playing rugby there and um you know grew
up with some some pretty good rugby
players
um that came out of there and it was
just a really good really good place to
to sort of grow up in what position did
you play well mate i was i was sort of
like what happened to me is that i was
quite tall i was sort of this height
when i was about 9 10 11. so
i i stayed and i had a little bit i had
a little bit of gas so i stayed in the
back so i was a sort of second five
center and then slowly got pushed out to
full back and then even further out to
the wing
um but that's that's sort of like the
position that i stayed at because
being this height i was able just to run
it straight and you know able to get
through players and so i didn't really
you know work out the fine arts of
fending and side stepping and you know
looking for space so as i got a lot
older and people started catching up
with me height and sort of weight wise
um yeah my i sort of got started started
getting kicked out the back and um you
know almost on the bench as well so that
was sort of my playing days for for
mobile boys and um
that i certainly enjoyed it and and had
a great time was that ever a dream of
yours to play professional rugby was
that bit of a goal for you i think it
was like i mean most i think kiwi lads
growing up you know they they want to be
an all black and you know i was
certainly that when i was you know
playing for mulberry boys
um it wasn't until i actually trialled
down at varsity down and down in dunedin
where i started maybe i just lost that
passion i lost that love but i didn't
lose that love for the game so my dad
were freed in marlborough
and um growing up like i'd always be his
water boy and you know it always maybe
i'd hold the flag from sometimes but i
never watched him as if geez that's
something that you know i want to be a
referee one day because i was i was too
engrossed and playing and you know i
wanted to be with my mates and and all
that so
it wasn't until university where i sort
of lost that that um i guess passion for
playing where he he just you should you
know give reference crack there's a bit
of a pathway there now so
um i guess you know i always like every
other kiwi you know just trying to grow
up play rugby and um and see how far you
could go so what how was it when you
first gave it a correct reference did
you love it or a tough gag like i don't
know i i still really can't remember it
the first day i turned up i tell the
story where um i was on cumberland
street in dunedin which is like the main
drag just um outside of north ground
and back then you know you you sort of
you received your emails on on the
computer and on the laptop you didn't
have a smartphone or certainly you know
i just i was just running the old nokia
brick back then
and um so this team was warming up on a
saturday and you know about quarter two
one
and i saw that you know they didn't have
a referee so that was uh i thought it
was a bit crazy and they're warming up
they're warming up and then i just
checked my emails and i'd received an
email on the tuesday saying that my
first game was
um on saturday at north ground at one
o'clock so the
two teams that were warming up and me
sitting there being like where's that
referee they're actually waiting for me
to turn up so
i grabbed my boots and um i had a
whistle that i had as well and i ran
over there and um
i had to borrow the coach's watch to to
kick the game off because i didn't have
my own watch
and my to this day like i'd love i mean
it wouldn't have been recorded or
anything but i reckon i would have been
awful because
um
you know every every year you referee
you look back to the year before and um
you sort of look at and you go wow okay
yeah i can't believe i was doing that i
can't believe i was making those
decisions and yeah and um you know so
this is a good
almost 12 years ago now so i don't
really know what i was doing as much as
you know potentially what i'm definitely
a bit better now than my first day then
did you have doubts after it did you
like enjoy the process or did you cop
any criticism out there while you're
doing it because i mean refs are never
shy of copping criticism yeah like i
mean we we cop a lot of criticism a lot
of it's you know part of the game in
terms of passion but i remember back
then like for me
because i'd really you know i didn't see
myself i was never going to achieve
being a great player um i just wanted to
stay part of the game so it was really
ticking that box for me you know i'd go
out on the weekend i'd refer a club game
in dunedin
and it got it just got me outside it got
me involved in sport
and i could just go back into my studies
during the week so for me it was just
about
you know i really enjoyed that aspect of
it because
you know it was a big part of my life
down to need and dunedin was a great
place to be able to do it because again
it's kind of a smaller town you can get
around you make a lot of good friends
and
um that meant that i could i could just
be involved in rugby still and i guess
it gave you a bit more time to focus on
your studies because you are a very
intelligent man i surgeon is it yeah
well i don't know if i'd say intelligent
but i just i just do the time and you
know put my head in the books and i
study medicine down in dunedin and you
know it's a six year gig
um and then once you graduate you do you
know um you do you do a lot of rotation
around different medical and surgical
specialties and i realized early on that
i really like sort of fixing things and
sort of hands-on stuff um so that sort
of moved me down the surgical route and
then um i found you know ophthalmology
which is you know eye medicine and you
know the benefit you can you can give to
people and patients and
you know some of the things you can do
is pretty amazing so
i did that for a few years full time and
then i was offered a full-time contract
to referee rugby
and i was lucky because i was kind of at
the point where i was you know working
full-time monday to friday doing on
calls during the week as well flying
friday for a minor team cup game or a
super rugby game saturday flight friday
do the game saturday come back sunday
and i was straight back into it on
monday so it was getting pretty full-on
and then it got to a point where
you know i was you know you might have a
clinic that it's meant to finish it for
but if anyone's been into the hospital
you know that you know you're probably
not seen until 7pm so there were some
clinics that were running well over time
just because the day was busy um and
then i was starting to miss flights to
games and then you know that would
affect the preparation for my next game
sorry for the game the next day and so i
really came at the perfect time and they
offered me this contract i thought well
i'm going to give it a give it a crack
i'll i don't know how long it's going to
last for they might do one game then
they'll punt me but
um
so now i've it's really good it's really
flexible so i can just work as a locum
in the eye clinics around around new
zealand and yeah it might mean you know
i work one to two days a week and it
really helps to get away from you know
you go back to copying the criticism you
know sometimes it's nice just to get
away from rugby so yeah
we can put some things into perspective
so do you actually perform the eye
surgery so like part of my job is like
i'll be a junior junior registrar so you
have your consultants doing all the
really big surgeries so like the
cataract operations
um you know they'll work at the retina
at the back of the eye and you know
fixed attachments and things like that
so what i'll do is like um you know if
you come in if you've got you know
something in your eye you've got an eye
infection or your eyes inflamed you'll
be i'll be the first person that you see
yeah um i'll assess you i'll treat you
i'll try and diagnose what's going on
and if it's something that i can treat
so for example if i just need to do a
bit of laser to fix
a tear that's at the back of your back
of your eye your retina i'll be able to
do that
um some people need injections in their
eye
some people just need you know drops
just to treat you know the fiction that
they have and then you know i'll book
them into to see me again in a few days
um so that's generally what it is and
then when you do go to surgery sometimes
and you're you're assisting your
consultant and they might say look hold
this whole bet and um you know you
really you know you're basically another
pair of hands for them so it's um pretty
exciting to be able to do that kind of
stuff do you feel a lot of pressure when
you're in those rooms more so than
refereeing yeah like um i think it's a
different pressure for sure you know
like the pressure that you get and rugby
i think is more it's more personal it's
like your name that's in the media is
your name is making the headlines that's
your picture on the front page yeah
versus this is you know in medicine is
actually you know you're trying to treat
someone's health and you know you're
trying to make them better um are fine
margins between making the right
decision making the wrong decision and
if things go wrong it can really affect
the long-term outcome for someone so you
you know the pressure here i think is a
lot higher and you know i've worked in
you know emergency departments before
where you know patients come in and
you're in the recess bay and you know
things are full on you know that's i
would say that's pressure
um because you know you're having to
make these decisions um with the help of
colleagues that are you know going to
impact someone's life potentially so
um so i always thought that that helped
me
because you know i've been in an
environment where there is a lot of
pressure involved
but also
you know the the rugby environment helps
me
uh in my medicine as well because you
know a lot of i guess parallels in
medicine and rugby is you know your
communication how you manage people
and that's what you have to do in
medicine as well like if you don't have
the right if you can't communicate
correctly or ask the right questions to
a patient they're not going to basically
tell you what's wrong with them and it's
the same thing when you're trying to
deal with a fired up captain or you know
a seven who thinks that they should have
you know won the ball when you know you
said actually they're off their feet so
um so there's some really good parallels
there which i've which i've enjoyed you
love it you love the pressure and talk
to me about um coming through the ranks
so obviously you're a young ref when you
first started out well i think it was
what 18 years old were yeah yeah i was
18 19 so i was sort of that first second
year at uni
you remember when you were playing
sevens for tasman and i'd actually drive
over from blenheim
um this is like years and years ago true
um
i'd referee all your training games oh
yeah and um so it's probably one of the
first times that i met you
and i remember like after the game sort
of came after the training you came up
and you're like um
i might say where do you live in the
house and i was like no bro i drove over
from bloom every day
and you're like oh mate look come on
come home we'll um we'll get you around
you can stay the night you can you know
come back to training tomorrow yeah um
now i ended up obviously i was i went to
back to blind and i um got back to the
family there but i always thought like
oh geez he's a good man and um that's
why it's always been been good to catch
up with you during during games um since
then i don't believe that was you i
can't believe that yeah
you've come a long way since then
[Laughter]
well that's the thing you've probably
blocked me out so far it was so bad
since then but um yeah that was it was
one of my first memories of him
bloody good times that yeah shut yeah
it's going back
and then you progress through the ranks
pretty quickly didn't you so you would
have been a young ref referring um
npc at the time how was that how was it
going into that environment yeah it was
pretty it was pretty daunting like um
i think then like we had a lot of
support so there was a an older group of
professional referees who
um they really sort of took me under
their wing and you know they're able to
you know help me in terms of you know
okay you have a young kid on the block
um there's a lot of potential there but
there's a lot of stuff that you need to
learn so i tried to you know learn and
take as much and as i could from them so
that when i did go out and do those
games
um you know my debut game which was
auckland versus bad plenty i just really
wanted to go out there experience it but
also a lot of it is
you can be told all the stuff around
howard a referee game you can read up on
the law book but until you're actually
out there
um
it's you know it's actually really
difficult to you know into it to you see
those pictures so um it really you know
all my learning really started you know
once you actually got in the middle and
you know you made some good decisions
you made some poor decisions you then
review the game and then
that's how you got better week by week
by week and um
i think back then it was it was a little
bit more daunting because okay the
players were a bit older than me yeah
but pretty quickly you know the players
got younger or i got older and then you
started realizing that actually okay you
got a bit of confidence you got a bit of
experience
um and you can just go out there and
just just do your job and people people
will trust that yeah and is there any
other is there any games that stand out
as you progress through your um ranks
yeah um
i think like
these been great games i've been
involved in um because the games are
great they've been games where you know
people necessarily probably didn't think
the game was fantastic but i was really
proud of how i refreed um there's also
really tough games that um i thought i
did a good job and but there's also
games where you know i didn't do well
and then you know that's that's where
your biggest learnings from
um so you know all those sort of
milestone games i think you know my
first my first heartland game um on the
west coast my first mitre 10 cup game
which is bunnings now
my first super rugby game which when i
was thrown into that one that i
mentioned before yeah and then my first
test match which was in samoa and then
my first tier one test match which was
in scotland you know all those sort of
levels um we were definitely
good experiences because every sort of
level is slightly refereed differently
to the neck so when you do reach that
next level you know you you really are
okay back to level playing field again
okay you've got to start learning um as
you go and until you get the experience
you don't really know so so they're all
really good and then like to top them
off with the world cup in 2019 and and i
think just coming back from south africa
even though during the time you know it
was a hell of an experience you know i'd
say that was really you know one of
those games that all
and probably the series you know that
i'll remember
for the rest of my career
yeah you spoke about the rugby world cup
there obviously being a rugby world cup
referee is one of the i guess ultimate
goals as a referee and that japan
tournament was unreal what's it like
travelling as a referee are you are you
all together do you travel all together
or what's what's it sort of look like
yeah so travelling um
when you obviously pre covered before we
had all this this business that was
happening now um there are about four
international windows that you travel in
a year and and that's on top of you know
super rugby traveling to um south africa
australia argentina and japan so four of
those windows you travel so six nations
rugby championship and then the two
windows that where the north comes down
here and then the south goes up north so
as a referee you you'd normally travel
and you'd probably be appointed if
you're on a series with
two other assistant referees and a tmo
now they went local so they would all
come from another country as well so
they'd fly in from france
and they might fly in from you know
england for example if you had wayne
barnes or luke pierce so you generally
all if you're in south africa you'd all
fly in on the monday and then you'd stay
together for the three weeks and you
know during those three weeks
you know you prepare together you train
together
you'd be in the same hotel and you
travel together to the different
locations that you do the games
sometimes if you were referring in the
november internationals you know you'd
fly up there and your assistant referee
might be from france they actually
they'd come back and forth um so you
just be by yourself the whole time yeah
so what what i really liked about it
compared to um i don't know like you
better know when you know you're
applying for me you know the number of
maybe four people trying to get around
to do something logistically was a lot
easier potentially than you know i've
been with nick berry jamie up brown and
glenn jackson all weeks players as well
and um they you know they really it took
them a wee while to get used to being a
referee in the way that we traveled
because they were very much used to okay
at this time we do this at this time we
got breakfast at this time of getting on
the bus we're all going together um so
it's a very structured day which you
know they really loved where for us it
was like okay
you know if i was referring that that
weekend i'd sort of lead the week and
say guys this is what i you know on
monday this is what i want to do today
um
we're going to train at nine o'clock
we're going to have a review session at
3 p.m
in between it's just your own time and
then we'll catch up to dinner at six um
and sort of every day you sort of do
that so it was it was quite good because
you could just decide okay all right the
weather's good all right so we're gonna
actually go for uh we'll go for a drive
down the coast or something we'll go for
a for a run on the beach together and um
versus you know having to be you know so
strict on what we're doing so
that's kind of what i guess a week is
for referee and um
obviously when you're traveling it's
it's good as well so that was that was
one of the bonuses of finally you know
getting back to south africa yeah um
because you know we've been sort of
stuck at home for the last two years now
and
i was getting itchy feet and the jobs at
home were sort of stacking up so it's
good to get away mate it's all
interesting stuff and at that rugby
world cup you were in charge of
referring japan scotland one of the one
of the great games of the tournament and
i think your performance in that game
was almost a 10 out of 10 performance
from a referee when you have a game like
that do you know you're having a good
game when you come off the field yeah
look i think i think you don't really
know until after you've blown the final
whistle because you know you could refer
your game
and you know in your own mind or you
know when you review you could referee
79 minutes of their game perfectly yeah
and then all of a sudden in that last
minute or you know one thing happens in
the game all of a sudden it's a it's a
train wreck yeah so it's it's all it's
more as a referee like you just want to
do a great job for players you want to
set up guidelines so they can adapt and
they can actually express their skills
um so then you know if you can do that
and then you walk off the game you're
more just relieved you know you're more
just like okay
i don't think they're going to talk
about me in that one i'm really proud of
what i did and you can just sort of
enjoy you know reviewing that game um so
when i referred that game i knew you
know like it was it was sort of like a
really disruptive week again because we
had the typhoon we weren't sure if the
game was going to go ahead
um and
we had you know this game that had you
know 70 000 people here a few million
people watching you know in japan
worldwide and um it really was a
quarterfinal you know like to to almost
do a type of playoff game where
everything was riding on this game
um again i just love the challenge and
um i thought i got a really good balance
of you know how i refereed and how i let
the players play and i think at the end
of the day you know the outcome was
based on what the players did and that's
i think what you want to do as a referee
just want to be in the background step
in when you need to if you need to but
otherwise let the players play and enjoy
it yeah it's awesome and you you
mentioned avoiding the headlines so how
much criticism do you get after a game
like a general game and how do you
handle it have you learned to handle
that because you obviously be copping
criticism for
any game no matter even if it is a
perfect game yeah you do like that's the
nature of rugby and and supporters you
know like i think supporters they think
you've had a perfect game when you get
everything that um
that the other team has got wrong and
you miss everything that they've got
wrong you know so they're always going
to have an opinion on how you referee
but i think that's like people are
asking hey what's the difference between
going between different levels and i
remember
going from mitre 10 cup to super rugby
like yes the game was faster but the
players are at a higher level so
actually they did a lot of the accuracy
for you so it was easier to refree you
know i've always said that um you know
you should really start people referring
at test matches because you know i think
that's a lot easier than potentially
doing under 15s where you know
everyone's just scrambling for the
ball um so you know that that that's
that that's like when you when you talk
about okay what's the hardest thing at
the next level it's really just that
that public attention or that external
attention that happens before the game
and after a game
um and i sort of joked you know like you
go to south africa and they love rugby
over there you know they've got
talk shows going all week versus in new
zealand you know we've got a few shows
on the monday tuesday and then you know
we get on with it and yeah you know that
full on there um you know even as we saw
with the lion series recently so i
always found and with social media now
you know um that's just probably open
access to a lot of individuals and
referees including and you know i've got
instagram i've got you know facebook
because it's a really good avenue for
you know when you're traveling
contacting friends being in touch with
family when when you're away as well
um but i've always said you know like if
you if you do a game in south africa or
you know potentially anywhere in the
world now if you only get five private
messages abusing you afterwards you've
probably had an alright game but
you know sometimes you'll get up to 15
15 20 and then you sort of know okay
maybe i did miss a ford pass um
well the sad thing is like it can get
quite personal like um you know these
are just people that i don't know but
you know they're talking about you your
decisions
um your family all that kind of stuff so
it gets it gets pretty negative and i
think
you know it's really hard because you
know i'm a human being we're all human
beings you know when you read that kind
of stuff
um
especially in the first few years it's
real real hard to sort of be able to
cope with that and deal with it and you
start second-guessing yourself and
second-guessing your ability
even before you've been able to review
your game you know you've literally just
got off um you're probably on the bus
ride home yeah so um like i mean so now
like okay i kind of i can i've sort of
grown up with it now where
i find it a little bit more funnier that
these guys can just just do that and you
know often i'll screenshot a lot of them
and share them with friends and family
and you know it just helps just by
talking about it
um but you know i know it's probably the
same and you know i've read i've read um
articles that also get stuck into
players too so i think that you know um
everyone involved in rugby you know no
one's really immune to it
um but certainly what's helped us you
know even before before the second test
um and south africa i just deleted all
my social media and all my apps
all my
newspaper apps as well just because i
just wanted to try and stay away from it
because i know that you know sometimes
even though you know i feel like i'm
pretty mentally strong
you know sometimes that one headline or
that one little opinion can just sort of
you know break the shackles and get
through and then you start doubting
yourself again so yeah um it's a tough
one like it's something that i don't
think is ever gonna change and you know
i mentioned some older referees um
before like you know glenn jackson and
bryce lawrence and all that well they
never had really that issue because they
didn't grow up with you know what we've
all got now with social media so
um it's definitely yeah it's definitely
something that um i think is that is the
big change from okay how do you deal
with it when you when you start doing
those big games and i think now you know
the more the more games you do
um you know the more times that you know
people will see you in your roof your
team and you know they'll be perceived
in justices against that team so yeah i
think you know that's why you know
someone like wayne barnes and nigel
owens all those guys you know they've
been at the top level for 10 plus years
and that's why they're fantastic
referees
but generally you know the more you do
the more the more games you know there's
going to be at least one game where
they don't agree with your decision and
then and that's all they remember you
for me
especially wayne barnes he's a perfect
example here in new zealand uh one ford
pass how many years ago was it
plenty and he's still cox today
he doesn't i feel sorry for him because
like he's easily one of the best
referees in the world right now and has
been yeah for a long time and and i
actually it was interesting so you know
once i sort of got to this level and i i
started understanding okay how do you
referee test matches i actually went
back and i watched that game um you know
because now when i watch a game of rugby
unfortunately you know i'm you sort of
referee it in your mind you know as
you're watching the game um so i watched
it from that point of view just to see
okay what you know does do people have
um an actual uh a say in action how he
referred you know did he do a good job
or not and i watched that game and he
like
he nailed it like he referred that game
so well yeah and then the four pass came
along and and i said well look any
referee that referred that game you just
never you're never in the position to be
able to see that you know like there's
no way i don't know i can't remember who
made that break when the the french
players but you know we referees we're
for your reasons because we can't keep
up you know with guys like yourself and
players in a game so you know back in
the day like they weren't able to use
the tmo to check for passes so i really
felt sorry for him because um
you know he was it was in a lose-lose
situation um with that unfortunately 100
has it ever put you off refereeing as it
has ever got to the point where you're
like oh
i can't be bothered copying this abuse
anymore i've had a guts fall um no it
hasn't you know i think for me
at the moment the the benefits of being
involved in those games um the feeling
you get after you've done a good job
after a game the travel um the people
that you to meet um
sort of outweighs those those perceived
[ __ ] at negatives at the moment but
yeah you know all it probably takes is
you know some experiences you know that
you know potentially you know that we've
had in the lines um
uh that you could get at world cups that
you know could really you know you know
be that be the tipping point for some
but i think at the moment like i'm i'm
quite lucky i've managed to sort of get
through the whole social media and
that side of things quite quickly
um so you know i'm able to just laugh at
that kind of stuff now and you know i've
done
um you know i show people and it's quite
funny like i remember being doing a game
with angus gardner once
and we were both copying stuff after the
game and i was only the assistant
referee and so we were just like showing
each other what we're what we're
receiving and you know it's just really
good to have a laugh about it because uh
matthew look
we definitely put our hands up when we
make errors and you know we we
definitely work hard to be accountable
we'll review our games so that we can be
better because if we don't get better we
you know we will we will stop getting
those appointments
um so we sort of just see it what it is
it's just you know someone who you know
is so angry that they can actually
search and sit down and even type my
last name correctly
um you know okay good on them but yeah
it doesn't really doesn't really impact
me anymore fortunately very good
but anyway mate what's what's the plans
for you have you got much of a plan in
terms of your referring career have you
got goals in line yeah mate look i i've
always just wanted to refree the highest
level like i love the challenge of
okay always okay okay what's the biggest
game and being involved in those games
and i really feel that over the years
i've built a skill set that um i think
helps those games and i think helps
players just you know enjoy those games
as well so for me you know you know big
goals for me were obviously the world
cup and um
the lion series so you know i've been
able to do that um so now it's just you
know just continually referring the top
levels a massive goal for me i just want
to do it for as long as i can
um i don't have aspirations or goals to
refer a world cup final i think you know
that they're unrealistic because at the
end of the day you know i want the all
blacks to to win the world cup final um
so if they want to if they're going to
win the world cup final well i can't
refer that because you know you can't
refer your own country yeah um
normally so um for me i just want to be
involved in those big games and and
referee at that level um as long as i
can i think you know the day will come
where uh you know hopefully i can you
know give all my learnings to a younger
referee and uh eventually one day that
referee will take over and and and
surpass me and i think that'll be the
day that i'll i'll hang up the boots but
um i'll just be really keen just to
to stay involved for as long as i can
and i think you know that on the horizon
there's another world cup in france
coming up in 2023
um there's another lion series you know
you roll that around again in australia
um coming up as well and then you know
another world cup after that i think you
know potentially i'm at an age now where
i could you know go go go to a few
um
and i know that if i can do that then i
only want to do that if i'm referring at
the absolute top level so you know i'll
try and keep changing myself to be
better and to keep doing that and what's
the hardest part to be able to stay on
top of your game in terms of age is it
just the fitness requirements the the
speed or just the mental fatigue of from
being a ref for so long i think it's i
think it's just the body you know like
um yeah
we referee for a reason just because you
know we don't want to take too many
knocks um and hopefully we don't
although uh brendan pickerel took a good
knock and they all that game in the
weekend which is good
i'll keep reminding him of that um
but it's generally like the older you
get the more experience you get you know
you've been through those those
experiences where you've learned from it
you know you've got those scars on your
back so the wiser the older you get um
the better you are as a referee you know
so that's why
you know someone like wayne barnes jaco
piper you know they've been at the top
level for so long because they've been
through all the ups and downs they've
learned everything and they're actually
at a point now where all those learnings
that have happened have meant that okay
they make mistakes they don't make a lot
of mistakes um during a game and if they
do make a mistake it's not they're not
massive just because of the time i spend
to the middle so you know if you keep
referring well like that you know you're
going to keep being selected so the only
thing that limits you is your body
and if you you know physically
keeping up with the game
isn't too hard because we don't have to
stay on side we you know we can run
these running lines where we we can chop
and change in and out of the d-line and
you know we can get to the next
breakdown um you know before the half
hit because we can just run there and we
don't need to stay on side you know we
can sort of just run into space
so
but you know the older you get you know
a lot of referees get you know um
niggles with hamstrings calves so a lot
of our gym work that we do you know
we're not trying to get massive um we
we're just trying to do um you know a
lot of injury prevention so you know
we'll work out you know lower body upper
body just so that we can stay fit and
just stay conditioned to be able to
referee because you know we probably
would probably run about nine kilometers
in the game and it's very much stop
start oh really yeah yeah so we we chuck
all the old gps units on just like you
guys and um
we yeah it's about nine
um but you know that high intensity
stuff is probably a lot lower than you
know what probably the backs would do
yeah um we're not having to get down and
up like a lot of the fords um so we're
almost like you know marathon runners
compared to
probably your sprinters or your middle
distance or short distance like some of
the players are
so if you can keep your fitness up like
that and you can stay injury-free then
you know that's why you get someone like
nigel owens who
but i think he retired at 47 i think
roman put right now french referee still
referring at about 45 drone gases about
45 as well so you sort of get to the mid
40s where um yeah if you can still if
you can still keep up with the play
basically by by staying on the field and
being fit then there's no reason why you
wouldn't be
wouldn't be continually being selected
because by then you know you've you
understand the game pretty well and how
it should be refereed and i think you
know people have accepted your style by
the end that um you know you should be
able to referee for a few more years do
you have fitness requirements you have
to live up to to be a referee yeah we do
we we get tested like um so twice a year
through world rugby um and you have to
run a bronco which is you know that new
sort of test i've brought in over the
last uh four or five years
um and i think like to refer a certain
level so if you wanted to referee um
bunnings nbc
um you got to get maybe under 5 15. oh
yeah um if you want a referee um at
testimental level you've got to get
under five
but a lot of the referees you know at
that test match level you know some of
the quickest would be running you know
four minutes 30. right i think um james
diamond in new zealand was a 425 that's
awesome yeah made us quick and you know
he blew us all away so most of us are
sort of between that 445 mark um
because you know to be honest like 4 45
is is really good um you know it's
amazing and you probably don't need to
be going any quicker to be referring a
game um
because the the big part about refrain
is that you need to be you need to be
fit to be able to make a decision and
have a clear mind so you need to be able
to you know run that eight kilometers in
the game be in the 75th minute an
alliance you know decide at 16 all and
then still have a clear mind after
running 50 meters to a breakdown to be
able to make the right decision so
that's that's really the most important
thing around fitness for us is is being
able to be able to you know make those
decisions after after you're fatigued
have you ever been in a game where
you're just completely gassed and you
can't you can't really keep up
yeah there's one game like um
and it was it was all of us really like
all the players i refereed um south
africa versus australia and bloomfinten
so i'm in the hive out at altitude
and bloomington was about 35 degrees so
it's hot as well and you know obviously
you fly into south africa you're flying
on the monday
and you know you're a little bit
jet-lagged but at our attitude you're
trying to train as well so you know i
try and run as much i can during the
week just to you know you know it's like
just to get those lungs
at that level and and mate i remember i
think for the first five minutes we
didn't have one stoppage um it was back
and forth you know israel was cutting
cutting through gaps we had um
you know hundred pound running through
for sale ever as well and it just went
back and forth back and forth at
altitude 30 degree heat
and um there was no stoppages for
injuries we didn't have a scrum and so
for five minutes and then finally i
think we had
like the ball got kicked into end goal
and i just uh there wasn't a grounding
but i was like mate guys we're going to
check this so we're going to take time
off and i think
everyone looked at me and they just
patted me on the back they said thank
you and all the water all the
technicians came on they've got the
water on and but yeah i was there was
one moment where i was absolutely gassed
um and it was really uncomfortable you
know because you know you're trying to
make these decisions you're running back
and forth
um but then funnily enough you know
after we had a bit of we had a bit of a
break a bit of water um we're straight
into the game you sort of just got into
that groove so you can win yeah it was
probably only time second one for for 75
minutes it was good if you make a poor
decision early in the game does that
affect you do you feel that when you're
referring the rest of the game yeah well
i mean that's i mean that's what that's
one of the real early things you need to
learn as a referee
is how you move on from a decision
whether you think it's correct or not
you've got to be able to um in a way
move on to the next decision with a
clear mind without any influence from
that previous decision because
if you're
if you're running around you think geez
i don't know if that last penalty was
correct or you saw it on the big screen
you're like oh that was wrong and then
you're thinking about that when you're
going to the next decision
well you might make that decision that
might get that might be wrong and then
it just started to start snowballing for
the rest of the game so you know early
on in my career that's that's something
really that you got to try and work on
um
i know a lot of people not a lot of
referees and and maybe players you know
you've got these certain things you do
during your game just to be able to you
know keep yourself in the moment
um i know some referees sort of um they
might replace their whistle take the
whistle off put it back on they might
slip there slap their thigh
for me i just i sort of just tell myself
um just trust and enjoy so
just obviously just keep enjoying the
game but just trust that um you know in
the moment you know you're gonna be
right nine times out of ten pretty much
and the reason that i've built that up
is that you know there were times in
games where i thought oh geez i'm not
sure about that decision and then when i
reviewed the game i was actually correct
and so that happened a few times where
and then i started realizing well
actually you know a lot of the times you
are correct so whenever you get that
doubt in your mind just move on you're
probably going to be right move on to
the next one and get that next one right
because
you know you will make
in a game of rugby a referee might the
decisions that they make
90 90 of the decisions might be accurate
um there might be 12 non-decisions in
the game so
decisions where um you know player came
in the side and they should have
penalized that and there might be maybe
two errors in the game and that sort of
across the board is what um how games
are refereed right now because you know
that's how it's how it's tracked so you
know like i know that you know in a game
you've got to be comfortable it's just
it's just making sure that you know
those big ones
um you're not getting wrong
um and you know that that's a that's a
big part of it and um you know like a
big one i had a few weeks ago was uh
marco korobiti and the australia france
game yeah got a few questions about that
one actually oh man i'll probably be out
i had a few questions myself um
but you know like the the thing around
you know what we're trying to do or what
we're trying to do is that you know
they're bringing in laws and it's kind
of like what i said you know you learn a
lot of it theoretically um and until
you're actually out in the moment you
know you're not you know you actually
don't know how to implement it um fully
so know in that moment um you know i
gave a red card because i thought okay
there's dangers come from distance we we
do have an angle with his um direct
contact to the head um so therefore it's
a red card even though every bone in my
body in that moment was saying
um you know this is not a red card and
that's one of the i mean that's one of
the more frustrating things for me that
happen after the game is that
um you know i've i've given bad red
cards before you know so i've learned
from that you know i've learned that
um
you know i even have like my we've got a
little booklet with your cards in it so
normally you just have a yellow and a
red like my booklet has yellow yellow
open it up yellow and then a red so like
i've gotta really go through to actually
give a red card you know like i've gotta
go through those barriers to actually
break through to be able to give it yeah
um so that was the more the frustrating
thing is i felt like i had learnt from
that um
when it came out that look okay there is
um
there is actually shoulder contact first
because the head comes forward and then
the head touches the shoulder therefore
you know it's mitigated down to a yellow
in the review i sort of looked at that
and i was like okay i understand that
like um and all i learned was ben just
just stay with your instinct stay with
your gut stay with you know the
experience and you know what's got you
this level to be able to make those
those correct decisions um so you know
that was that was a big a big part of
that but in that moment you know i i
knew that it was a big decision it was
four minutes into a test match yeah
which was a decider you know as one all
and i just thought look
we're to review we're going to look at
okay whatever this decision is whether
it's right or wrong we're going to
review it after the game what i must do
is refer the next 76 minutes really
accurately and really well
and um and i knew like i'd refereed uh
really well all season super rugby and i
just knew look again just trust and
enjoy so enjoy it but trust that you
know you're going to be able to refree
the rest of the match and it was a
really challenging game you know it
stayed tight right to the end um but i
reviewed that game and i thought look um
i thought i refereed really well but
kind of like what i said before um you
know was that game a pass mark you know
probably not because in that one moment
um you know i gave an incorrect decision
which definitely impacted the game yeah
i mean as a referee you don't want to be
you don't want to do that so
um i was just grateful like you got it
you gotta take those learnings on board
and i think you know i get a situation
like that in the future i'm definitely
gonna be better off because i'll know a
way
where look we'll still give red cards
but i'll just be a little bit smarter um
in terms of okay looking at that picture
fully and actually trusting my gut more
and and to be fair i believe that that
experience actually helped me you know
deliver you know performance that i
needed to do in the line series and you
know be smart around the foul play
um which was just happening left right
and center in that game made it's so
hard eh and is the game referee
different in different hemispheres
because we talk about red cards and
there's 100 times more red cards up in
the english premiership than there is at
super rugby so is there different
interpretations for referee around the
red cards well like this shouldn't be
because you know world rugby put out the
guidelines for what a red card should be
and you know that has been constantly
tweaked and adapted and you know
potentially that's why you have
um you know differences that are
happening between the northern
hemisphere and the southern hemisphere
but i mean i also think that the style
of rugby is different between the north
and the south so therefore you know you
know you've played up there therefore
you know there's probably more of those
um one-on-one contact situations you
know versus maybe in the southern
hemisphere where you know the bulls
probably spit a bit wider so you know
you try and actually beat someone on the
outside so there's more of a lower
tackle around the legs to stop them
um potentially because actually you know
the law and you know what we're told and
you know we have regular meetings with
the north and the south you know we
should be all following the same sort of
guidelines and i guess like one
difference is that you know as kiwi
referees we had a whole season of super
ugly at those new laws before everyone
else did so i felt like we got a really
good full year under our bout of
experience so we sort of got through
that learning process
where you know a few years ago when the
northern hemisphere finally got rugby
going on they started going through that
process as well so it took them a bit of
time to probably catch up to to we were
at in terms of understanding you know
foul play and the tackle and and i guess
the new the new law trials mate it's all
so interesting i love it but as always
we've gone to our instagram and like i
said at the start you've come up with so
many so we better crack on to some of
these questions before
we have to turn it into a mini series
but
first question
have you ever thought about swapping
codes and riffing in the nrl um
look i've never thought about it um but
you know when i watch a game i think
geez that's pretty easy like they they
use the they use the tmo every try um
i'll only have to count the six two reps
but yeah two riffs they stand 20 meters
away so you know now that i think about
i reckon you know that'd be a pretty
cruisy job um so maybe it's like a
retirement gear i can do i have thought
about like um
we had one of our one of our ex-referees
became the cricket manager uh umpire
manager in new zealand
and i thought geez that'd be that'd be
an interesting one you know like being
able to be a cricket umpire but then i
realized like i
i've got concentration that last you
know i could probably you know do an 80
minute game you know maybe there's a bit
of extra time you know squeeze an extra
20 minutes um the concentration i think
cricket umpires have to to be there on a
five day all day standing at the crease
would be really tough so i i haven't
really considered i think i'm just i'm
still just trying to improve and get
better refereeing so we'll just we'll
keep it that job first mate it would be
cool to see it would be cool to see a
ref uh
switch codes it'd be like the big tj
announcement after the afternoon area
well we had like um john o'brien who
was a i think he was like the world's
best netball umpire and now he's
referring and bunning's nbc doing a
great job he hit us in the weekend yeah
yeah yeah i think that's probably one of
his first bunnings games so um yeah he's
doing a great job but i reckon like one
game they should get a rugby referee is
on that is it the black clash or the um
you know you know when they get the
footy players yeah should do that but i
reckon
that's your
i'll be a bit there'll be an
embarrassment oh you just be like sixes
and you know no balls and stuff so
you know we'll keep i'll keep myself in
the middle of the rugby field no mate
we'll sort that one out surely the next
umpire the black clash
right oh next one um biggest spray from
a player
um look i think um you get a lot of you
get a lot of sprays from players
um i'm sure you've yet it's me some
something once um yeah and again
but you don't really you don't really
remember you know like a lot of it is
passion um
so you know i've had a lot of sprays but
then you know often a player will come
up and say look i'm sorry like it was
just in the moment so you move on
um but i think you know one of the
funniest ones it was i think a few
months ago when i had the hurricanes
high in this game and
kelsey yeah i know um and
and i did i did that thing you know like
because football umpires you know they
actually pull out the yellow card early
and this is something you know i do
watch other umpires in different sports
yeah so they pull out their card early
so i don't get players rushing in and
you know people know that okay the
referee's gonna deal with it so i sort
of tried to do that in union as well
where like i've got a yellow card coming
up i'll just pull it out so that okay
everyone knows so i don't need the other
captain complaining asking for a yellow
card and obviously when i pulled it out
he um he was like you know what's that
and then i think he said something like
um
just trying to have a bit of fun
and mate i um
i don't like like my style of my style
of how i like to referee is you know i i
always listen um
i you know i'll always engage with the
player and i'll never try and um
ignore them yeah but i just i bit back
and i said like not tonight so he said i
was just trying to have a bit of fun i
said not tonight
and it was just it was just it was just
a reaction and but he was he was really
good about it and he um he came back on
and said look okay well i'll i'll be
better now we'll have a better we have a
bit of proper fun so
um that was that was probably one of the
one of the good moments oh it's so good
and we've had heaps of questions sent in
about cozy what is dane coles like to
ref like i don't i don't understand why
there's all these questions about him
because i reckon he's fantastic yeah um
i reckon and like he's one of those
older players now where i think he's
been there he's done that um he
understands the game he understands
referees as well he knows that we're not
going to get everything right um so you
know if he sees like a mistake that
we've made or you know we give him an
answer that he doesn't really buy he'll
just you know he'll roll his eyes but
he'll always do it with a smile yeah um
but he'll go out you know but he'll do
that just after like you know putting a
massive head on someone and
um and then he'll drop and then we'll
drop a shoulder on someone as well so
um he's certainly like i think he's a
great player to deal with i think
there's a lot of players especially in
new zealand um you know because we've
been able to refer them a lot more um
just because we've stayed locally
it's been really good i think we've got
some really good characters in the game
for sure and a lot of them have come on
here actually okay tips for young
referees wanting to make a career in
refereeing yeah like i think um that's a
real common question and i get and um
one one thing i always i always there
were probably two things where i think
it's really important to
like play rugby you know or at least be
a fan of it and watch it because the
more you watch rugby um or you play
um the more you're obviously gonna enjoy
it but also the more you can actually
understand
um how games how games are played it's
like i say that about commentators as
well you know you the commentators that
we have right now i've either played or
they've been commentators for 20 years
so i was always amazed that you know
they'd be watching a game and they'd
just sort of understand the nuances
really well but it's just because
they've watched it you know they're a
student of the game so i'd say just try
and be involved or watch as much rugby
as you can but probably the biggest
thing is just always ask for advice
i'm you know i'm referring some of the
top games in the world now but
i'm still always asking for advice
because you never know you know
what kind of gym you can get either from
a from a player from a coach from
another referee from a spectator just
watching and i remember you know when i
was young and coming through i never
tried to think that i always knew what
knew everything about a game because you
don't and you never do
so because i always wanted to get better
i always knew that okay
there's a lot of better referees out
there and there's a lot of better people
that understand the game more than i do
so okay just trying to understand how
much they know and then um i'll be able
to progress for them
and that's what i always try and do with
referees like i'll always be open to
trying to you know push on them as much
as i know so that they can at least take
a little part of it adapt at their own
into their own style of their own way
and then go out there and and and
hopefully do a better job than i could
do you know that's that's definitely my
goal and i know that over the years you
know i've taken certain um you know
skill sets from from particular referees
like you know the way that nigel owens
manages players
um glenn jackson's reading the game
um wayne barnes has you know just
experienced jaco piper's technical
ability you know i try and you know take
aspects and and mold that into my own
game and i could only really do that by
asking and and talking with people
because you know it's you don't know
what you don't know right so it's really
important when you know you do get
people's opinions and i mean like like a
lot of opinions that you get in social
media you know you sort of gotta dredge
through
um all the negative stuff all the bad
stuff but you know there's definitely a
lot of stuff there and and you know i've
only got to position now by by listening
to a lot of people and um you know that
would be my biggest biggest advice to um
genie referee that wants to um you know
potentially carve a pathway and refrain
because it's you know it's fantastic
fantastic career yeah
mate that's good stuff and that sort of
leads on to the next one you mentioned a
few good referees there but who is the
best referee in the world in your
opinion
um so me i think easily you know it's
wayne barnes um
and so that's current referee and i
think you know he's probably been one of
the best for the last few years as well
even though you know he's right up there
with um you know yaakov piper you know
nigel owens is right up here with them
you know will just loved him and the way
that he
he uh the style that he refers the games
and also you know as one liners that he
he pulls out um but but for me like um
barnes you know he's a leader within our
group he's just been there for so long
you know like he he referred that
quarter final against all blacks france
i think he was like the age of 31 or
something which is
which is pretty incredible like um i
went to the world cup i think i was 31
or 32 as well so you know for him to
actually do a quarterfinal and and still
be there now you know he's just
developed so much and you see that in
the way that you talk to him now and the
way that he referees you know he he
refers referee games really well and i
think
in terms of like the all
income you know encompassed package you
know he's he's sort of got that um but
it's only just it's only been through
time and
um you know getting getting denied you
know re-entry into new zealand and all
that kind of stuff so um
he's he's definitely up there right now
um but it's good like i think even in
new zealand though like we've we've got
some a really good group of young
referees right now sort of at that super
rugby level um
and you do go through a cycle where you
know you've got a really strong group of
french referees that will be strong for
like a three or four year cycle
before that it was probably south africa
with craig dubia and you know andre
watson and all that and before that was
probably new zealand i think now as new
zealanders we're almost getting back to
you know we you know we've got like
brendan pickerel paul williams james
diamond mike fraser who now are all
getting tier one test match experience
and we're all you know sort of
mid-thirty so you know hopefully it's um
strong means it's strong for new zealand
it's only gonna help i think you know
super rugby in the new zealand game
because you know you've got these top
referees with top experience
um to help you know referee the game and
then you know hopefully that will
benefit um those players who then go on
and play international and play for the
all blacks and
um you know further on in the future
okay next question does he get much
grief from new zealand public when he's
out and about nah not not really like i
think um
it probably only really started you know
because i've been referring tier one
test matches for maybe four or five
years
um you know went to the world cup like
even was part of the world cup final but
because i don't i never referee the all
blacks um and you know the all blacks
you know didn't make it through you know
like you don't you know people don't
really notice that okay there's actually
a new zealand refrigerator new zealand
referees out there you know referring at
the highest levels as well um you know
in six nations and i guess in the
november test matches either so i quite
like that it means i can come back to
new zealand and no one really no one
notices me at all i'm not like a player
i can go and have a have a beer and you
know no one's taking a photo of me it's
it's fantastic
um but then you know when i did refreeze
the all blacks um two years last year
and in sydney that's when i did notice
that actually okay people like oh my
gosh wow you you referee you refresh
that level that's amazing
yeah like it is it is pretty cool um
i guess you know you do become a bit
more and and i think you know now
because i i have been involved in bigger
games
you know you referee some of the big
games in super rugby um
you know and especially because we've
done every single game in new zealand
like normally would be in south africa
and argentina away from those headlines
yeah um
you know all of a sudden you are you
know oh i'll be in okay if you know how
can this team win with him and how can
you know you know he's is he favoring
one team again and like where's he from
in new zealand and all that kind of
stuff so
you do get you do sort of get noticed a
bit more just because we've been more
local um yeah
but you know
that's that's just part of it and you
know i certainly love i certainly liked
it when i could be doing those games and
you know not being recognized or noticed
at all because i mean that's kind of
what i want to be like on the field as
well you're not really really noticed or
recognized either you can sort of just
do the job and get out yeah and you
mentioned people mentioning about uh
referring their side so we got heaps of
questions about that about oh why does
he why does he hate the hurricanes or
whatever
do you go into a game ever
go into the game nervous about referring
one side because you feel like you have
a bias towards them eg the all blacks
australia game no like absolutely not
like the um
the
like the way that i referee you referee
based on instinct and what happens in
front of you so you know a player makes
a tackle and doesn't roll away bang you
got advantage you know you don't have
time to actually go oh that's my mate
from high school or oh that's um
you know that's an all black there so i
actually i'll bring my hand back and you
know like it would just be too obvious
um yeah but you do because you're you're
referring on instinct because you know
you've trained yourself just like
players you know you know if you're
reading a gap and you know passing you
you do that based on instinct as well so
um so for me you know and like in new
zealand especially you know i grew up in
tasman
i studied in dunedin um i lived in
wellington and um
you know now i live in auckland so you
know there's
you know the cat there's no bias there
it's just like i don't you know as a
referee you don't you don't really
support a team and and i like how
that was sort of proven when you started
getting people referee their own country
so last year especially about
australians were free australia new
zealand then you know i refuse new
zealanders australia as well
and i think we're all a little bit
apprehensive to see okay how is this
actually going to work but i was really
confident knowing that well this is how
we refer your game we just go out there
and refree what's in front of us um
doesn't matter what color jews they have
on and and you know that really happened
when i refreed um the all blacks you
know i just refreed and it didn't really
matter i think i yellow carded two all
blacks in that game you know it doesn't
doesn't matter they're from new zealand
they were they were going to be yellow
cards whether you're wearing a a gold
jews or welsh jews an english jersey or
or or an all black jersey so
um
but i understand how you know people
will always say that but you know at the
end of the day the longer i've been
referring for a long time now
um the people that those people's teams
they would have they would have lost at
least once when i've been referring with
them and they probably blame me for that
so
um i think just the longer yeah the
longer you referee the more
um the more you're gonna be perceived to
be like that so um unfortunately uh i
don't think it's gonna change right
there okay next one have you ever
considered going back to being a rugby
player oh mate i've played social rugby
before um but only because you know i
still get given free boots you know if i
had to buy my own boots i think that
i wouldn't but um
no like i've never considered because
you know i've reached a level where i
would never have reached this plank you
know um being involved in tier one test
matches
um and you know that's that's you know
write down so i probably would have i'll
never have um you know played in
bunnings or heartland you know so um for
me um i'm really grateful and and i love
you know what i do as a referee and um
because i'm always like i think i said
at the start like i always want to keep
challenging myself and keep changing
myself to be better for the game
um if i went back to play rugby i mean
i'd i wouldn't be challenging myself at
all i'd just be like
i'll be a challenge for the referee i
tell you that like i'd definitely be one
of those players that would be telling
me to be quiet i remember i play social
netball and i feel sorry for them i do
sort of everything that has yelled at me
from the weekend or sent to me on social
media i bottled up and i think i let
loose on these
social network umpires um
i've got a rain i gotta rain that in um
but now i haven't considered going back
i'd be on i think i'd break in half the
first tackle that
um someone did that's classic
okay um
on that who is the hardest player to
referee um who's the hardest like
the it's that is a hard question because
everyone
at a professional level you know
everyone's
everyone knows the laws really well
everyone's really competitive so
everyone you know they do challenge you
but they do challenge you respectfully
so i think um i guess the hardest
players to referee are you know a lot of
a lot of the captains around the world
you know you get the alawin joneses the
sierra khaleesis even sam whitelock you
know because they know the law really
well and their job is and i do like an
open communication channel they can be
quite difficult to deal with because you
know they're coming at you with
questions they're challenging your
decision decisions even though it's
respectful um but it's always putting
you on notice you know you're just
trying to have to manage that situation
constantly
so they're sort of really challenging
players in terms of how um
you manage with them
um and then other you know other players
just like a lot of sevens in the world
you know um like the tom carries the
dalton populis the artisavis you know
they're so quick to get on the ball
they're so low when they get on the ball
that um
you know sometimes you question yourself
you're like wow did you know because
because because they're so quick now you
really have to be on the money and you
have to be out there right quickly to
actually read okay should they be
rewarded with that penalty or actually
should they
um be penalized for being off their feet
or for not rolling away so you know that
i think just the accuracy and the skills
of players are really challenging um
compared to what it was like maybe five
ten years ago
interesting eh okay next one
if you could change one rule what rule
would you change um look what i would
change is stop changing the laws every
year um i think that happens a lot you
know where we just get really good at a
set of laws and interpretations and then
because it you know it takes some time
you know it's like players you're sort
of adapting to a new style
and then all of a sudden it's changed
then we have to refresh everything again
but
if we weren't going to do that if we did
have to change anything i would actually
try and change the um
the like the outlaw oh yeah um which is
a really
technical piece and like you'd know as
as sort of a fullback winger where you
know if the depending on the plane of
touch the bulls either in or it's out
you can be actually running outside the
field of play and if the ball hasn't
crossed the plane of touch you can hit
it in but not catch it if you hit it in
in its play on you can score a try
actually lying outside of the field of
play and then hit the ball down and then
go so there's all those things where you
know as an assistant referee like yeah
when you prepare for a game like that's
the stuff that you get pretty scared
about because you're thinking it
happened so quickly and like where's the
plan of touch where is it is he out is
he not is the foot on the ground is it
not i just think look if if the players
out they can't touch the ball and the
ball is out so i would i would like
man i would like them to change that law
because then and then all of a sudden
you know you're made to the hurricanes i
think corey jane into the whole um
if you you know you can jump from
outside the field to play and as long as
you catch the ball and land in
yeah it's it's it's play on you know so
that's another real niggly one where in
law it's it's right
um so
yeah i think they could definitely do i
think in basketball
uh it's real simple it's basically if
the ball's out or if it touches someone
that's out then it's out you know so and
you know that's a great sport so um
i think you know we should we should
definitely take a leaf out of maybe
there there but yeah okay one more rule
change and then then we'll knock it on
the head yeah i'll be happy with that
okay this one you might have been
playing actually thoughts on the
nasimanu
v ryan marshall hit that still
circulates on the socials right that is
that is like folklore at mobile boys
college um
rugby that one it's it's amazing um i
don't know if you've seen the clip but
you shouldn't
get it you must be on
i was on the other wing i was 15 meters
from that
um
who came out of nowhere i think
i think ryan marshall was still getting
tackled right now um
but there was like that was you know i
would say you're a bit of a golden era
for mobber boys we were really led well
by um guys like joe wheeler and quinton
mcdonald and you know we i think it was
like the press cup final against
christchurch boys and you know they they
were unbeaten all season until we bit
them in the round robin and then we
played them at home at the mighty
landsdowne park
um and yes so nasimani was i think the
the number eight for um cautious boys
and
mate he just came out of nowhere and you
know i um
i can't say that i've ever wanted to
um be on the end of that because you
know i've seen that video clip and the
video clip still sort of resurfaces and
mate he um i feel for the guy but he got
up and um
he kept playing so yeah it was it was it
was a good it was a good tackle and that
was your last game of rugby two wasn't
it you retired out of sympathy oh mate
but it probably was i was like look i
i was very close to putting on the 11
jersey that day
um but you know like i've got a good
right boot so i'd better put on the 14
and then um you know just it just showed
me like you made the great right
decision then and we better we'll we'll
leave it there
what's the refereeing decision from that
hit play on or
yeah 100 like um yeah like it's almost
you give a yellow card to the to the guy
that got tackled just to give him the 10
minutes you know just to catch his
breath again
but um yeah it was a good good low hit
full rep from distance um
he just he just smoked him so now i love
i love that clip it's um
it's definitely one for the ages from
mobile boys yeah one of the greats
okay next one
have high tackle rules gone too far
well yeah i think i think they had um
maybe two years ago or a year ago where
pretty much every bit of head contact
was a red card yeah um and now i'm not
i'm not exactly the best person to talk
about that with the red card decision i
gave a few weeks ago but um i think the
benefit now is that the guidelines it's
it's actually called a head contact
process now so we've actually been given
um
we've been given a bit of latitude now
to actually okay yes there might be
direct hip contact there might be direct
head contact in the game rugby and there
is there's a lot of direct head contact
in the game of rugby
close to the goal line pick and go
even even like when you are trying to
make attack or if the player changes
their position in the last few seconds
you know it's very very dynamic you know
it was it used to be that red cards were
for intentional acts of foul play where
you know this player must leave the
field because you know we can't have
that in the game of rugby and then it
kind of blended into this
foray of um
okay legal what what were legal tackles
you know initially trying to make a
legal tackle but it gets it slightly
wrong by a few centimeters all of a
sudden that's a red card as well so the
difference between a red card and a play
on became like you know one centimeter
um and that's where you know we're
getting a lot of red cards there's a lot
of red cards in the six nations there's
lottery cards in the rugby championship
last year as well and i think we were
getting to a point where like our hands
were tired as referees you know as soon
as we saw direct head contact
um slowed down on the tmo screen on the
big screen
we're almost having to try and find a
way to not give a red car but if we
didn't do that our bosses were going to
kill us in the review you know and then
we wouldn't get another game so we're in
a real tough position but now
i guess it sort of evolved where there's
more emphasis on
the actual actions of that defender um
you know how much dane like are they are
they initiating the contact are they
providing a lot of the high danger
because of the way that they're actually
attacking the player they're either
jumping into it they've come from
distance to swinging arms shoulder
charge or are they stationary and are
they just trying to soak the tackle and
actually that dip from the bull carrier
is the mitigation around okay why this
might not be a recard and why it might
actually even be play on you know so i i
like we're moving i think there's
definitely um you know further
developments that we need to make
so that you know the game does need to
remain safe you know the player is
getting bigger faster stronger so those
hits do have an impact especially with
everything that's going on with
concussion
but we do you know the answer to that
question we do need to be a bit smarter
just around you know the impact that
those rear cards are giving so making
sure that we're getting those right
decisions um for the game
great answer okay next question
do you think you should be punished for
faking a head high i'm guessing it's a
little bit like what the french uh eight
did when he got hit by kurobe totally
yeah i think um and you know we we
haven't really seen that in a game of
rugby you know um a lot of it happens in
football and i think that sort of acting
or that faking or um
you know
is something that we we cannot allow to
ever come into the game so i think you
know
that was really i guess a cornerstone
incident okay so we worked out okay that
shouldn't have been a red card yeah we
also worked out in the review when we
talked to um our reviewers and with all
the world rugby referees is that if we
get a situation like that again when a
player does
um you know
you know they're trying to get a penalty
out of you or they're trying to um fake
an injury or fake where they've been hit
well we need to go hard on that player
either by you know at least reversing
the penalty or even yellow carding or
you know at worst it seems red carding
that player as well because um as soon
as we start getting players doing that
um you know it's going to be a really
bad look for the game so
um so we i don't think i think if we if
we saw that in the future and certainly
part of my game now you know the way
that i you know i'll go back and i
review my philosophies and how i refree
again part of my blueprints i've added
in that okay if i get a player that acts
like that um if i have to yellow card to
tackle fine i'm going to make sure that
i i sanction
um that player as well so i think
potentially in that in that situation if
i had that again that exact same moments
and you never get the same type of high
tackle again you know so it's always
going to be slightly different but i
think i would have you know would have
yellow-carded crowberry because he still
gets them high even though the contact
um shoulder first in into the head so
yellow cart but it would have yellow
carded
the french captain as well
and
you know maybe even restarted with the
penalty to australia you know because
there's got to be a real firm stance
around around that in a game and and
that's what we do as referees you know
we we see okay instances that have
happened in the game and it might be as
simple as a tackle decision or something
more complicated like that high tackle
we review it and then okay we add that
into our game for next week so if it
happens and
in the future just like i said um then
you can pull the trigger on okay what is
okay the better outcome to do and that's
why you know guys like wayne barnes
because you know they've been through
all that before like he's he's made all
those mistakes before you know that's
why he he you know he makes you know
when c referees a game when yoko piper
refused a game everyone goes well he
managed that really well or yes that was
a great yellow card yellow card because
he's been a decision before and he's
actually being able to do it again
because he's reviewed it mate that's
good stuff i'm looking forward to that
seeing the first yellow card for a
hollywood yeah that's going to be coming
soon and it's going to change the game i
love it yeah it'll be good and i'm going
to say hollywood actually right you
can't hollywood see ya
yeah good stuff okay
this is interesting when is it true that
ben and angus gardner hired a
convertible in south africa and ended up
at a pub where there was a shooting oh
yeah like um uh we
so you know you sort of asked earlier on
the podcasts around you know what you do
um you know during that week and like i
think it was like on a wednesday we sort
of decided to have a day off and
um
we you know hired a car and just drove
down to the cape of good hope um just
you know better sightseeing just to get
out bit of fresh air
and then you know drop the car off and
then we walked out and to get some
dinner somewhere um and then you know
literally you know we left probably like
10 o'clock went back to the hotel and
then the headlines the next morning was
you know literally at five past ten ten
past ten um you know a guy walked in
there and and you know it was a shooting
so
you sort of realized that um
you know we
you know we get this amazing opportunity
to travel um and sometimes you sort of
realize you know you think yeah you know
you're in this amazing bubble where
nothing can go wrong
um but you just gotta you just gotta you
know keep keep in mind that you know you
are in a different country
um you know things do happen that are
out of control and you know it's really
important to obviously look after
yourself and look after you whoever
you're traveling with because you know
things can change pretty quickly
um so that doesn't mean like i don't
think you should be ever you know you
shouldn't be stuck in your hotel room
the whole time you know because i think
i'll just go crazy with that but um
yeah look i mean things can happen
everywhere in the world um
so certainly when you are traveling like
um
i know you know teams have been through
that as well you know when they travel
overseas it's really you know you've got
to be so careful with um with what
you're doing now so
um yeah that's
that was definitely you know one
situation that opened my eyes geez
that's crazy so you guys don't have a
security guard because i know all the um
super rugby teams when they go to south
africa they've got their own personal
security guard but you guys you're
you're on your own tour are you yeah
like and that's i didn't realize that
teams had security guards either um
so you know we'd go to sierra care you
know three or four times that you know
not just you know see everything all
over the place but yeah it would just be
like sometimes i'd be there by myself
um and i'll be doing my own things and
you know you obviously you try and stay
as safe as you can um you know certain
places that you don't go to
um but the other times you'll be
traveling with maybe two or three so it
would just be the three of you and you
know you do try and stick together the
whole time but you know like you know
you walk into the supermarket you walk
into the training field you walk into
the gym
um yeah it's uh you know you just got to
be so careful um when you're traveling
right that's crazy yeah south africa
dangerous place but um who is the best
player you have red carded the best
player i've recorded yeah i don't really
try and fondly think of my red cards um
too much like
got a big big post posters on the wall
of the guys
yeah it's normally like in my christmas
cards i write to them like i'm so sorry
it's been five years since i recorded
you but you know just want you to know
that
but like it is a thing you know i um
obviously i never like giving red cards
um
because i think they impact the game so
much and and you know now they're so
technical you know these red cards that
we give yeah um i think you know one of
the one of the first ones i ever gave
was
i think jason emery
down in dunedin i think it was in my
first year where um he went up and i
think he took billy larue out in the
year and billy larue landed on his head
i think it was um sharks
um and then you know i know i've given
you know other ones out as well where
you do you do sort of because i've only
given maybe maybe four or five in my
career um so you don't try and
obviously make it you know rack them up
but you do you do remember all of them
and i think um you know certainly the
ones you know that i that i've um that i
do remember you know like there was one
where i gave in um sydney a few years
ago
um it was the sun wolves versus um
uh the red so so it was in brisbane and
it was one of those ones that was
another learning one where you know we
got a bit of a punch at the bottom of
iraq and you know i sort of said well
punches the bottom of the rack to the to
the head it's a red card and it was
really light it was like a um it was
like a
sort of touch of the year really um but
because we slowed it down because we
used the tmo yeah that player was
recorded yeah matt i feel you feel
really bad as a referee when you when
you make decisions like that that you
know that you don't truly believe in
when you review the game and when you
know potentially it's impacted the game
and i remember i saw that player a whole
year after
and i went up to him i was like mate
look i don't know if you remember but
obviously i recard you last year and i
just want to say sorry you know and um
that for me was a bit of a weight i
lifted off my shoulder because you know
i felt so bad and i think his referees
you know people i don't know if people
realize this or not but you know we do
feel really connected to the game um
and obviously we don't want to be part
of the spotlight but you know naturally
we brought into it when we have to make
these big decisions when we have to be
in front of the screen for a tmo
decision when we have to make game
defining decisions you know you do beat
yourself up quite a bit um in your
reviews
um so um you know that was something i
was carrying around for a long time and
you know it was just nice and you know
he was really good about he said mate
look um you know no worries we all we
all make mistakes and then we moved on
so um you know it was a really good part
of it so in terms of answering that
question around red cards like um i i
can't remember all of them
um
but yeah they're never nice to to give
and soon i'm sure they're not for a play
have you ever been red carded no never
only two yellows in japan one for
throwing the ball at someone
oh good
i couldn't believe it it was my first
yellow professional rugby throwing a
ball at someone because he wouldn't let
me throw a quick throw in but yeah did
you hit him yeah one of those
oh yeah but not very well if i knew i
was going to get yellow
kicked it
okay two more
okay what's one odd law that we wouldn't
have heard of
um i think that one that i mentioned
before you know that law where um if the
ball was sitting in goal okay so if it's
in
you know if i'm attacking and the ball
is sitting in the angle that i want to
score or try and i can actually be lying
outside so i could be outside the the
end goal and if i'm lying on the ground
the ball is on the ground in the end
goal i can actually put my hand out and
score a try so
i could be there with my hand on the
ball scoring a try
and my whole body could be out
and i'd be walking over as a referee
being like like i know no one's gonna
like this but bang that's a try
you know cue the headlines but you know
that's under law 11.4 whatever
um so that's you know that's a that's a
real unusual one that now the problem is
because it hasn't really happened
i think ever
and that's that's why it hasn't been
changed it's so hard to because because
the ball has the ball has to be on the
ground right right it can't most times
the balls and lingo is sort of popping
up and they'll have to slightly put the
ball down but on that rule am i right in
saying that the ball has to be flat on
the ground to do that it does because if
the ball if the ball's off the ground so
it's bouncing like from a grubber or or
whatever then as soon as it's off the
ground if you touch it and you're in
position so then if you're out then then
you're out but the ball's on the ground
because you touch it
on the ground first and it's not in the
air then for some reason it's a try so
it is a crazy rule hopefully it happens
soon hey the same game the hollywood
yellow card happens it's all it's gonna
all come to fourth well yeah you may as
well just have it all in one game eh you
know just chuck it all in one game and
then we can have a big review afterwards
i just hope that
um i'm in the stand watching again i
definitely don't want to be the referee
for that
fair enough okay last question what's
the best piece of advice you've ever
received um
i remember i it was actually after one
of those incidents that i talked about i
i remember talking to one of the coaches
um i think it was tony brown
and he he said to me he was like look
referees okay you do a lot of work in
terms of learning the technical side of
the game um understanding the laws
going out there and referring
but you know what players want to do and
what coaches want to see is actually a
referee that's just enjoying the game so
obviously being accurate but just
enjoying the game as well because
if if a referee is enjoying the game
then you know that rubs up rubs off on
the players and then you know the
players
i guess naturally enjoy it a bit more as
well they accept your decision a bit
more as well so
um he just made a comment he said look
um mate like go out there and just enjoy
just just enjoy the game trust your
ability um and then everything you know
you obviously work out afterwards so i
really took that bit of advice and that
was sort of you know only a few years
ago where you know i've done a lot of
referring and you know you know studied
up a lot and you know done a lot of
games and you know that really opened my
eyes to just be like well
yeah okay i've just got to trust okay my
ability is referee
and then the only next thing you do is
just enjoy it enjoy the 80 minutes um
and i think you know when you do that
naturally you have a bit of game because
you know mentally you're more relaxed
and i think it definitely helps the the
flow of a game so that's that's one
thing like among many many different
things like um
uh that people you know throughout my
career that i can be very grateful for
um i i also think like some of the best
advice i ever got was um in club rugby
in dunedin you know at the aftermath you
know you'd always go and you'd have a
beer you have some hot chips and then
the winning coach would come over and
shake your hand and then the losing
coach would come over
chuck their beer down
you knew you're in for a 20 minute um
and you know a bit of enlightenment but
you know they were really really good
those supposed those times and actually
that's that's a big part of what i miss
in terms of um
uh the international stuff now is that
apart from six nations you know you have
a big formal after match but in terms of
super rugby and and other test matches
now especially with covert um you know
everyone you blow the final whistle you
know you walk off and then you know
everyone's off again to the next game
you know so it's pretty i guess are you
professional and serious in that sense
so you certainly missed that
the good times that um i'd say mate that
is some excellent advice from you and
it's awesome to get an insight from one
of the best referees in the world so
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast and going through your journey
what an incredible journey that's been
and mate like i said i've got so much
admiration for referees because it's
such a hard job as
um so much more than people could ever
imagine i guess and the amount of
criticism that they caught for getting
decisions wrong and almost a possible
game to referee perfect
mate it must be just such a hard gig but
it's awesome to hear how cool it is from
your side and the whole process of the
journey so really appreciate you coming
on the podcast giving up your time and
thanks for coming on mate yeah cheers
jimmy it's awesome to be on what a lead
and um yeah thanks for having me
obviously look i'm on lockdown so i've
got nothing else to do so um
but it was awesome mate to catch up with
you again and um yeah thanks um thanks
very much having me on no worries mate
i'm in lockdown too so we're all on
we all are yeah
[Music]
[Music]